(▲_◉)   Hey guys, I am so excited right now
(▲_◉)  because I am on the set of the new POWER RANGERS© movie.
(▲_◉)  Somehow, they let me on the set here.
(▲_◉)  I loved POWER RANGERS©,
(▲_◉)  I still do.
I even got....
a POWER RANGERS© action figure.
I'm thirty.
(Upbeat music)
- I'm with Becky G who is playing the yellow Ranger in this movie
which ironically is your favourite color, right?
- yellow is my favorite color, yeah!
-The Power Rangers was like the most quintessential 90's series, I think ever
Would you say that this still has the 90's vibe or is it a total update?
- I think it's a total update, I think there's a lot of things that we're doing
Whether it be, the scenery
or just the way we're dressing
or how we're fighting
that's like keeping the true essence of POWER RANGERS©
but, it's definitely updated
- and cool.
- Every POWER RANGER has their own unique weapon, zord, costume
You got a great one, but is there any power ranger that you are a little jealous of?
no, cuz' mine's the best
cuz' your's the best.
you get to fly man
yeah, that's the best. Cuz' everyone wants to fly
Both the girls and the guys are pretty BadAss in this film
But, who wins out? the girls or the guys?
i like the grls, i feel like (chuckles) obviously I'm gonna say that
that would be so weird if i was like, oh definitely the boys
i do like is the relationship, between trini and kimberly
there is a really nice friendship, that kind of blossoms throughout the movie
im here with RJ, the BLUE ranger in this POWER RANGERS movie. Now-
-do you feel like a blue ranger in real life?
You're kinda like i dont wanna say, the nerdy type
But you're kinda the smart one right?
Well yeah. i mean i'm smart in real life but i'm just not as oddly, you know, configured as Billy
ok
that's the only thing, me and Billy are two totally different people
alright
but I am really smart and i like to do things that might end up in a really bad explosion
But hey, for the time being...
Explosions are fun
Yeah
How Close is Your Red Ranger To What We Show In Original Series